c'est une nouvelle loi bien controversé
qui n'en a pas fini de faire parler
d'elle et notamment dans les rangs
américains signée jean ping cette loi
adoptée par le comité permanent du
parlement chinois est accusé par ses
détracteurs d'être liberticide et de
constituer un moyen pour pékin de
museler l'opposition
promulguée à hong kong un peu avant
minuit mardi 30 juin par la chef de
l'exécutif qui a ri l'âme
cette nouvelle loi sur la sécurité
nationale étant les pouvoirs de la
justice chinoise en matière d'atteinte
grave à la sécurité nationale menaçant
de prison à vie tous crimes portant
atteinte à cette dernière
cette loi permet de réprimer quatre
types de crimes contre la sécurité
nationale à savoir les activités
subversives la sécession le terrorisme
ou encore la collusion avec des forces
étrangères
il n'aura pas fallu plus pour susciter
l'indignation d'une partie de la
communauté internationale et washington
en tête alors que pas moins de 27 pays
du conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'onu parmi lesquels la france
l'allemagne ou encore le japon ont
condamné cette loi mais face à eux un
groupe de cinquante trois pays ont
apporté leur soutien à pékin en saluant
l'entrée en vigueur du dispositif et en
estimant que cette question ne devait
pas être discutée au conseil des droits
de l'homme le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mike pompéo à lui menacé l'
empire du milieu de nouvelles sanctions
déplorant je cite un jour triste pour
hong kong et pour tous les amoureux de
la liberté en chine les etats unis ne
resteront pas les bras croisés pendant
que la chine englouti hong kong dans sa
gueule autoritaire des menaces prises
très au sérieux par pékin qui pointe du
doigt une nouvelle tentative
d'intimidation et d'ingérence dans les
affaires internes du pays
nous ne vous avons pas provoquer de quel
droit êtes-vous agressifs avec nous la
loi imposée mardi ne regarde pas les
pays étrangers
quant aux pays qui ont déclaré qu'ils
imposeraient de lourdes sanctions à
certains responsables chinois
je considère qu'il s'agit d'une logique
de bandits de son côté le chef de
l'exécutif hongkongais car ilham a mis
en garde washington contre toute
ingérence
alors que pékin a affirmé que ces actes
sont condamnées à échouer alors hasard
du calendrier ou volonté de marquer les
esprits
la date de sa promulgation coïncide avec
le 23e anniversaire de la rétrocession
de hong kong à la chine par la grande
amiens